o se convirtió en el tercer país en
superar la fatídica cifra de 200.000
muertes por kobe 19 en medio de la
situación el gobierno intenta aumentar
la velocidad de la vacunación en estos
días se va a ir anunciando cómo vamos
destinar más vacunas y se van a aplicar
más vacunas porque
van a participar todas
dependencias del gobierno federal
los gobiernos estatales
y se va a reforzar el plan de vacunación
la inmunización se ha ralentizado en el
país por retrasos en la entrega de
vacunas lo que ha llevado al gobierno a
señalar el acaparamiento de las dosis
por parte de los países más ricos hasta
el momento tan sólo el 0.6 por ciento de
la población ha recibido las dos dosis
del fármaco una cifra mucho menor que la
de su vecino eeuu que ha vacunado ya
totalmente al 14% de sus habitantes
algunos temen un nuevo repunte por la
relajación de la conducta social de cara
a las celebraciones de la semana santa
pues yo creo que la gente debería de ser
más consciente digo ya está llegando a
la vacuna pero no es para que empecemos
a hacer fiestas reuniones y todo lo que
queramos no de acuerdo con las cifras
oficiales en méxico se han registrado
más de 2 millones 214 mil contagios y
200.000 200 muertes sin embargo el
propio ministerio de salud del país ha
asegurado que estas cifras podrían ser
mucho mayores debido a la falta de
pruebas generalizadas en la nación